when you appreciate what you do have you
create more of what you want that
effortless action that just sort of
allowing oh I was thinking about that
and it just showed up that's how life is
supposed to be abundance begins by
feeling abundant need motivation watch a
top ten with believe facia what's that
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a woman
who went from being a PR party girl to
becoming a New York Times bestselling
author speaker and spirit junkie she's
Gabrielle Bernstein and here's my take
on her top ten rules of success volume
two
[Music]
okay let's kick it up with rule number
one appreciate what you do have if
you're in that job where you're feeling
like this isn't working for me I'm not
into it I'm mad about it I get I get
upset every time I walk into the office
the thing that you're missing here is
that that she's looking at me she's like
what's she gonna say I need to I need
you know I give it away got me give it
to me the thing that you're missing is
that when you appreciate what you do
have you create more of what you want
[Music]
appreciating even the job that isn't the
one that you want forever actually helps
you attract the next career path and you
think it's counterintuitive because
you're thinking well I don't want to
appreciate this thing I don't want
that's sending out a message to the
universe that I want something I don't
want actually no the more you appreciate
what's in front of you the more you
become a magnet for what it is that you
desire so if you appreciate that job
that's not that great and you bring an
energy that's a little bit more of a
high vibe frequency and you show up to
work and you've got a better attitude
and people start to like you a little
bit more because you're in that
appreciation of whatever is around you
and they start to see you a little bit
differently and then maybe they give you
a raise or maybe they see some potential
in you or maybe one day you're just in a
really good mood because you've been
appreciating everybody and you're not
you're not mad anymore not complaining
on your Instagram about how you hate
your job and you're walking through the
office and you're in a really good mood
and you get in the elevator and you bump
into somebody and they say Oh what do
you do and you say I'm a copy editor at
this company and boom vibe they said oh
how interesting we've been looking for a
copy editor because it's your energy and
your appreciation that creates that
opportunity so the more that you're in
an energy of lack or fear or negativity
the more likely you are to deflect the
creative possibilities in your life the
more you are to deflect the new
opportunities and the less fun you have
real you know what I mean like the key
to attracting what you want people is to
have fun straight up have fun rule
number two men
best what you want so for our audience
can you define what exactly is
manifesting manifesting is acquiring the
experience of what it is that you want
to feel and being and living and
believing in that experience and then
allowing that experience to come into
form manifesting is very creative it is
the process of using your power energy
and being in that presence of your
high-powered energy and allowing the
energy to co-create with the energy
that's around you so you're vibrating at
a high frequency I'm vibrating at a
frequency uh we've done a lot of work
we've cleaned up a lot of our own crap
we leave in ourselves today
yeah and that act that energy of
believing in ourselves has attracted us
together today and brought us into this
space where we together are co-creating
and teaching if I hadn't cleaned up my
side of the street and if I didn't
believe in myself the way I do I would
never have manifested being on marietv
there's a really nice line from A Course
in Miracles which is the metaphysical
text I teach and it is miracles occur
naturally and when they're not occurring
something has gone wrong that
interesting it's a good one right so
what happens is is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh I
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our anger
towards the past that future tripping
and projecting all of that energy gets
in the way of allowing all of the
miracles to occur naturally rule number
three change your perspective the third
step
obstacles are detours in the right
direction so maybe you can begin to look
at your obstacles of maybe that divorce
is a opportunity a detour in the right
direction an opportunity to start to
love yourself some more maybe that loss
of that job is an opportunity to begin
to do that thing you've been dreaming of
maybe that diagnosis is an opportunity
to get closer to God take that in let's
reorganize your obstacles right now what
are the opportunities what is the detour
in the right direction in what way can
you begin to turn it upside down and see
it
as an opportunity to thrive and an
opportunity to get more connected to the
truth rule number four be authentic
early in my career I was always trying
to be someone else I tried to be the
cool girl or the successful girl who had
it all but what I've learned is that to
be truly confident I didn't have to try
so hard I merely had to strip away those
pretenses to release the blocks the
presence of who I truly am when I became
more me I started living my purpose of
confidence and taking action on my
dreams and that's the lesson all the
world wants from you is your authentic
truth when you truly get that you'll
feel the confidence to step into your
purpose own your power and make an
impact in your own unique way think
about that today think right now about
what makes you you when do you feel the
most authentic and genuine rule number
five give love I have a very important
lesson that something I've been applying
in my own life in a girl friend of mine
called me yesterday and she said that
she was feeling really attacked and
judged by someone at work and my
response was don't defend yourself don't
fight back don't judge back your work I
said to her is to the moment that you
feel judged an attack do something
immediately to make somebody else feel
loved so when you feel as though someone
has attacked you judge do you bully do
you done anything to make you feel
inadequate or unlovable do the opposite
do the exact opposite go and do
something to make other people feel good
so go make somebody feel lovable
adequate and good enough and that simple
practice of just taking yourself out of
the knee-jerk reaction to to fight back
or defend but instead to go give love
that can change everything for you when
you feel judged immediately go give love
go do something kind do something
compassionate do something loving that
will be the quickest way to stop the
momentum of the negative energy there
are way too many haters out there
there's so much negativity there's so
much bullying and there's so much
attacking judgment and that's why I
wrote an entire book about this topic so
my hope for you is that when you feel
judged or attacked instead of attacking
back you go give love you do something
to make somebody feel good you do
something that's based in compassion and
love and joy you make somebody you make
someone feel good about themselves rule
number six improve your productivity
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start I found personally
being in business for myself for the
last 20 years that I have been a little
overly productive I almost did too much
and I was constantly multitasking and
making things happen and just moving so
fast that ultimately I really burnt out
and I started feeling brain fog I was
feeling disoriented I couldn't focus I
was feeling like even though I for so
many years was priding myself on the
fact that I could get so much done at
one time I actually don't think I was
being nearly as productive as I could
have been so I hit a bottom recently
with this productivity overload and I
realized that I had to change my
patterns I had to change my ways I was
then blessed I said a prayer I said I
need some help with my brain fog and I
need some help with my productivity
issue and I that day got an email from
the dr. Oz Show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
dr. dr. Mike Dow and me and Mike had
been in touch many years for many years
just because he didn't been an author we
were published by the same publishers
and Mike had we had written a book about
brain fog so that day I'm like thank you
universe you're giving me exactly what I
need I go on dr. oz with Mike and I'm
backstage with him and I'm like listen
I'm feeling so chaotic and I'm
multitasking so much and my but I feel
like I've got brain fog and I'm
forgetting things and he look to me he
says how much are you doing at one time
and I said Oh Mike I'm doing a million
things at once I have a thousand tabs up
on my screen and he's like these are big
brain no nose and they're also
productivity no nose is what he said
because he said that the more I try to
do and the more I try to multitask the
less I'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that I want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day to make a list of the five
most important things that I need to do
that day
not do number two until I've completed
number one and then once a complete
number one move on is number two then on
to number three and if I don't get
through all five in one day I'll just
pick up the fifth the next day or
wherever I left off I'll pick up the
next day and to really stick to that
list and not move back and forth and not
try to make a million other things add
it on to that list and just be really
committed to that five task list I did
it I started to just be very clear about
the five things I was doing in a day I
told my team I made a list in my base
camp which is where we keep all of our
notes and I made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
I'm doing throughout the day as a result
of making it super clear and conscious
to myself that I was only gonna do five
things I have been more productive I
have created more have been more
intuitive I have been more inspired and
I've been more creative rule number
seven don't give energy to your fears
Cheryl says what is Gaby's biggest fear
good question
you know I think that I think that I
don't even want to say them out loud
yeah how about that
cool I say if I be yeah because I don't
want to bring energy to it yeah sure I
like that you know expanding on that bit
we all have fears you know no matter how
committed to love we are no matter how
deeply deeply connected we are to our
own our own spiritual practice and to
God into the universe we will always
have fear you know unless we somehow
become enlightened which is possible but
we will live with fear and it's it's
it's not that the fear goes away
completely as the spiritual student it's
just that you don't believe in it
anymore so when you ask me to share my
fears
it's like talking about something that
it's like not true for me so of course
there's fear and they pop up and they're
you know it's present but it's not real
for me so it feels like like I'm doing
the world a disservice to say it out
loud
rule number eight make feeling good your
priority as a teacher of the law of
attraction I believe that abundance
begins by feeling abundant when you take
on the energy of what you want to create
your desire becomes your reality many
people think they'll feel good once they
have that money in
the bank but the truth is they'll have
that money only once they feel good
so make feeling good your number one
priority rule number nine follow the fun
I live up in the country most of the
time and I have a very good a new friend
she just had a baby she's up in the
country living in the country and she
kept her her apartment in New York City
because she's like I'm a New Yorker he's
gonna keep my apartment you know she's
cutting checks every month and she's not
there she said my landlords raising my
rent I don't know what to do and I was
like okay let me ask you a few questions
I said how does it feel to think about
writing those checks every month to
something that you're not using and she
said oh that does not feel good I said
how does it feel to to think about
getting that baby in the car driving
down to New York City finding a parking
spot on the street of 13th Street
walking up for four flights and stares
with the baby and she said oh that
sounds really overwhelming
I said well Laura how does it sound to
save that money get cozy in that house
you have up in the country and then when
you want to come to New York City just
get the fanciest apartment you could
possibly get just get like $1,000 a
night apartment because it doesn't
matter because you're saving that and
she was like that sounds really fun
Laura texted me yesterday that she did
not resign the lease so follow the fun
follow the fun follow the fun this is
the lesson here we're always like you
know where do I want to be what do I
want to get to but we're never asking
ourselves how do I want to feel and the
moment that we start to ask ourselves
how do I want to feel then everything
changes our point of Attraction begins
to shift and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is be
the light so we've been talking a lot
about ourselves how do we deal with
friends loved ones who are going through
the same challenges that we
discussing fears anxiety nervous not
living their purpose of that what about
if it's the people around us that are
really struggling so be the light right
so I think a lot of people want to
change the people around them they want
to say you know read this book or watch
this video or do this meditation and it
doesn't work you have to the only
requirement for for membership as a
spiritual student is the desire is that
is that what is that wanting and so if
somebody doesn't want that then then
you're gonna be you know a broken record
so be the light practice your own
transformation get grounded in your own
spiritual healing and and live it and in
the expression of your light you will
reflect that on to others and they will
recognize their own light in yours so
you have a much more like a much higher
likelihood of elevating somebody and
healing somebody by just being the
presence of that light being that
presence of that transformation now I've
got a really special bonus clip on how
to speed up by slowing down that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your business in your
life and if you're feeling bold leave
your answers in the comments below here
we go question number one what three
things can you appreciate right now
number two what perspective change do
you need to adopt and number three how
are you gonna make yourself feel good
this week
I think that lately I've been I've been
sort of accepting something that I've
always heard over and over again which
is sort of you know that the you know
you can speed up by slowing down which
is you know sort of a old you know age
old spiritual belief systems like you
know the more you tune in the more
happens around you and I always preach
that and knowing that but I'm really
like really slowing down enough now to
believe it yeah yeah amazing because I
think it's so important that everyone
here is inspirational statements we hear
inside we hear wisdom but it takes so
much time for that gravity of that
statement yeah boys sink into our hearts
and our beings and it's it's okay to
know that it takes time I love that you
say this because it's it's a practice
and it's a path and it's a commitment
and and to your point you you can have
this daily path daily commitment read
spiritual books practice meditation why
people like yourself and be part of this
conversation in your own unique ways and
then there may be that moment in time
where you wake up and you're like there
it is you know I get that thing that
everyone's been talking about it get
that mantra that I've been preaching and
it drops in the most important word ever
if you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check out the
volume one top 10 rules that I did on
her the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
you could say all the right things but
if you don't think it if you don't
transform and clean up your thinking
then you're literally polluting the
planet